enables 17th appearance overall 3-0
opponents hitting only 188 against him
and definitely a different role for him
and earlier we saw him in the bullpen
kind of trying to
stay with his regular routine but he had
to come in and come out of the dugout
to start the ball game and the decision
to start canable and have price come out
there's a shot right down to turner for
the out
[Applause]
[Music]
drive had a little down spin on it the
o2
rogers
ground ball to the left craig turner
picks it up behind second base throws
rogers out and there's two gone
2-2
got him swinging
three up three down for corey knebel so
the opener gets the job done here's more
numbers on gray making his 24th start
yeah for john it has been fastball
command the secondary pitches his last
couple starts not quite as sharp he's
also been bitten by baseballs that have
had eyes
24th start
and this one hit right through the whole
left side of base hit
and turner
who is chasing a batting title now
as the quick hit and the dodgers with a
man aboard turner runs
and max walks dodgers have set up shop
in the bottom of the first inning first
and second and nobody out 3-2
and it's popped up
midfield fly rule this will be an
automatic out
and that is a big first out
and this one in the air to left field
joe
and there is out number two gray's
payoff pitch to bellinger is hit towards
right center field and it is caught by
taylor motter going to his right out
there
and the dodgers leave them bloated
one on nobody out for diaz it'll come
back here canel turns fires to mookie at
second there's the turn
double play
dave roberts will come get him david
price
will come in to face ryan mcmahon with
two down
in the second inning so the bulk innings
guy
david price the left-hander will take
over 2-2
a little flare to shadow left center
bellinger on the right makes the catch
oh he had to go a long way
but bellinger
catches up to it and the ending is over
runners at second and third and one out
he connor joe the lead off man and left
fielder once again and the pitch from
david price is hit in the air right
field moving back mckinney still moving
back onto the track reaches up and makes
the catch
tagging and scoring from third is modder
over to third is hampton connor joe with
the productive out the sacrifice fly and
the rockies lead one to nothing
that's skipped in the dirt
but the dodgers have kinley and the
rockies on the ropes
there's a ground ball to short they'll
get a run in
if they trade two outs for it an
expensive run
ties the game
one run a piece as turner comes in to
score
this ball is lined to right field and
deep mckinney going back he leaps and he
can't make the catch
story had to wait he's headed towards
third and he'll stop there
so it's an opposite field double
storey's watching
it's off the tip of his glove and then
it falls right at his feet and story the
start stop
watching him sliding into third base
there's the star he comes back you gotta
touch the bag again
he makes a face to stu cole
and there's a ground ball to betts
so that's a really good job by mcmahon
behind oh and two and the rockies take a
two to one lead
and this ball is just
foul
naturally it was at diaz because
the leah said hey in it fair let's see
how close it is oh that's that is super
close
skip rope
that's why one of the first things you
learn is go down and foul back and fare
want to know to chris taylor who struck
out swinging in the second inning
mckinley on two and one
a fly ball down the left field line it
is high and is deep and it is gone a
home run into manny woods chris taylor
who had been slumping with a high
majestic
shot down the line his 19th home run of
the year and the score is tied at two
[Applause]
this ball
at first caught double play
it's just a protect yourself there we go
puts it in play to right field mckinney
coming in and he'll make a running catch
head high
in the air to right over toward the
corner mckinney on the run at the track
makes the catch
the pitch well got the loss
krone hits a high fly ball to right
center field
ranging over his bellinger he
makes a hop-skip catch
got him on a change-up
2-2
on a change-up
that's how he struck out turner earlier
in the inning
2-2 and the fastball catches the outside
corner taylor's gone
there was a walk to will smith el monte
ends up striking out the side
another throw oh my god out at first
base
elias diaz with that cannon of his just
picked off trey turner
there he is quick snap throw that ball's
out of his hand in no time good job from
cj
block the bag
slap it straight down and let trey go
right into it yeah he's out oh man what
a throw
great tag by crone
and for the third time tonight
the basers are full of dodgers
smith tonight has walked twice and
struck out
the 3-1
that's into left field hit muncie's
gonna score here comes murky betts
behind him throws up the line a two run
single for will smith and the dodgers
take a four to two lead
aj pollock to pinch hit on the pitcher's
spot
a flare right dodgers are going to add
on turner comes in to score
rounding second on his way to third is
smith and he's out
but the run scored first
and it'll count
and the dodgers put three on the board
in the bottom of the eighth inning
and have a 5-3 lead
in the shallow center here's bellinger
handling it and that's the ball game and
kenley
with his
341st career save tying raleigh fingers
14th on the all-time list dodgers
get a w here tonight he even up the
series 82
and 48 the record they stay two and a
half behind the giants